comment ça va vous allez bien on va
aujourd'hui se parler d'un moyen
efficace simple et très rassurant pour
venir protéger vos biens électroniques
on va parler d' assurance et en règle
générale quand on parle d'assurance il
ya un côté qui est pas très très sexy
mais je vais vous expliquer pourquoi
justement j'ai essayé de faire cette
vidéo en partenariat avec clint ça fait
quelques mois qu'on est en discussion
avec clint qui m'ont proposé de parler
de leur assurance en disant nous on veut
réinventer l'assurance changer la donne
il changer la façon dont les gens vont
consommer de l'assurance pour leurs
biens électroniques
l'idée c'est que vous native et votre
assurance que lorsque vous en avez
besoin vous l'utilisez à la demande
ça m'a aussi surpris parce que pour moi
l'assurance notamment pour les
smartphones on va vraiment se parler de
smartphones non on n'a pas d'objectif
d'une façon générale mais moi j'ai
vraiment concentrés aujourd'hui sur le
smartphone en guise d'exemple parce que
en règle générale je ne sais pas si ça
vous est arrivé lorsque vous allez
acheter votre smartphone dans n'importe
quel magasin est bien arrivé au moment
où le vendeur vous dit vous avez acheté
un smartphone qui coûte cher quand même
il faut l'assuré vous avez quand même
pas parti avec le smartphone de cette
valeur sans l'assurer parce que si vous
arrive le moins de problème tout
l'argent est perdu c'est complètement
foutu le discours est pas faux mais il
ya un côté un petit peu anxiogène qui
est en train d'acheter vos smartphones
c'est dans un moment plutôt heureux et
on vous dit non non non non non il ya un
gros problème
acheter ça vous coûtera temps par mois
et au moins derrière vous serez protégé
ça m'est déjà arrivé de le faire et vous
retrouvez tous les mois avoir un
prélèvement qui tombe pendant que c'est
plus de 12 ou 24 mois que vous ne pouvez
pas arrêter et vous vous dites mais il
faut que j'arrête ce truc parce que j'en
ai pas besoin et je paye tous les mois
pour rien donc voilà ça c'était
l'assurance pour moi l'assurance de
smartphones voyez iard il y avait un
côté un peu
ah voilà ça donnait pas envie et
justement quand clic est venu me voir et
bien j'ai trouvé leur démarche
intéressante et c'est pour ça que je
voulais la partager avec vous alors bien
évidemment cette vidéo sponsorisés mais
si j'avais trouvé ça risque pas
intéressant bien évidemment je ne vous
en aurez pas parler on se met au clair
directement je me suis ensuite demandé
est-ce que clic
c'est une énième compagnies d'assurance
alors oui et non oui parce que derrière
vous avez zurich assurances qui existe
depuis plus de 150 ans mais l'entreprise
kling telles qu'elles existent a pour
vocation de changer complètement la
donne en terme d'assurance parce qu'on
est sur une assurance qui est 100%
digitale donc axé sur un public
collectées qui consomment des biens et
des services électroniques qui pour moi
le premier point principal et c'est
jeudi à plus important quasiment le plus
important c'est que vous n'utilisez
votre assurance que quand vous le voulez
par exemple vous allez acheter un des
derniers smartphones à la mode vous avez
votre smartphone vous êtes contents vous
entre
et vous vous assurez vous les toqués
j'ai besoin de mon assurance mais pas
tout le temps par exemple je suis dans
une vie qui ne bouge pas
particulièrement qui est tranquille je
le crains pas pour la casser pour le vol
je ne vais pas sortir mon bien trop
souvent mais par contre je vais partir
dans une semaine j'en sais rien moi à
paris ou en voyage ou n'importe où et là
j'ai plus de risques parce que plus de
manipulation puisque à l'extérieur je
crains pour le vol et compagnie donc ce
que vous faites c'est que le jour du
départ où la veille vous l'activez et
dès que vous l'avez activé vous êtes
couverts vous passez une semaine dix
jours en vacances ou à paris où peu
importe vous rentrez vous la désactiver
hop elle ne court plus donc ça c'est
vraiment extrêmement rassurant et vous
venez consommer de l'assurance à la
demande et vous avez pas une assurance
qui va courir tout le temps et vous ne
payez surtout qu'en fonction de vos
besoins
au moment où vous la d'activé dont vous
avez également la possibilité d'assurer
un bien tout au long de l'année si vous
le souhaitez on rentre dans un contrat
un peu plus classique mais si par
exemple vous êtes tout le temps en
déplacement et que vous créiez l'abîmé
notamment votre smartphone vous pouvez
le faire bon je trouve ça un peu moins
sexy mais si vous voulez vous pouvez
deuxième point positif c'est le prix
parce qu'on est sur des tarifs les moins
chers du marché
troisième point positif c'est 100%
online vous avez une application et vous
faites tous dessus je vous manque
l'application on la retrouve juste ici
clic
une fois que vous êtes identifié vous
allez retrouver le produit est assurée
ici j'ai une assurance maarten pour un
iphone et ce 2020 il est protégé
si vous allez sur la gauche les pouvoir
ouvrir un sinistre et si vous allez sur
la droite vous allez pouvoir couper la
protection l'activent la désactiver là
par exemple j'ai pour la désactiver vous
et ça vous marque tout changement d'état
vous êtes sur le point de mettre en
pause
votre assurance vous ne pourrez plus
déclaré de sinistre vous devez rester
hommes pendant au moins un parent vous
perdez toutes les protections de votre
iphone
est ce ça il faut le savoir n'oubliez
pas que vous ne pourrez pas armé tron
avant au moins un jour donc si vous
coupez c'est pour une journée pouvait
venir le désactiver extrêmement
facilement pour là on va pas le faire
mais voyez vous avez qu à cliquer là hop
et sous 24 heures pourrait venir ensuite
le réactiver à votre convenance
vous avez la liste de vos produits vous
avez votre profil en bas et vous avez
tous les produits assurer les produits
non assurés ici n'y en a pas donc ceux
qui sont désactivés et ensuite vous
cliquez sur le petit plus en bas et vous
allez arriver dans la liste de tous les
produits vous allez pouvoir assurer
alors vous avez tous les smartphones
classés par marc et ensuite pas produit
une amazone à des carènes un peu la
liste est vraiment vraiment exhaustif il
ya même de quoi faire vous avez même des
produits energy
ce système vous voyez quand même
beaucoup beaucoup de choses des montres
connecter pouvaient venir assurer aussi
extrêmement facilement des écouteurs
jabra apple bang & olufsen berdier
mixbeat ce buzz j'en passe et des
meilleurs des tablettes apple samsung
archos asus ya tellement de marques des
ordinateurs apple les nouveaux et
compagnie j'en passe et d'autre des
plans personnalisés
si vous souhaitez si vous êtes plusieurs
des pactes et clover si vous avez
plusieurs produits a assuré puis les
pack famille pour me rassurer toute la
famille et profiter de 25% de remise
et puis ensuite des consoles xbox
microsoft nintendo sony et des caméras
soient panasonic add-on des go pro tout
ce que vous voulez vous avez quand même
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de produits à
venir assurer si vous voyez donc il ya
beaucoup de produits on est sûr de
l'assurance sur des produits
électroniques et on va pas forcément
venir assurer les produits de la même
manière vous allez pas forcément assuré
une xbox qui va rester dans votre salon
par rapport à une intel de swico pouvait
emmener en vacances si vous partez temps
en temps et bien vous activez
l'assurance quand vous êtes en
déplacement quand vous êtes chez vous
vous n'avez pas nécessairement le besoin
un ordinateur c'est pareil ça leur dit
qu'ils restent chez vous ils vous buvez
pas le café de sucre vaut ce n'est pas
le renverser et bien vous n'avez pas
forcément besoin de la sur m6 vous
partez en dehors de chez vous en voyage
en réunion que sais-je encore il peut y
avoir un sens vraiment à venir l'assuré
c'est la même chose pour votre
smartphone vous êtes plutôt nomades
penser à l'assuré et quand vous restez
chez vous tranquille pourrait venir le
désactiver donc vous ne payez vraiment
quel usage et ça c'est vraiment très mal
et vous n'avez pas besoin de vous
dépasser dans une agence ou de contacter
n'importe quel service qui pourrait
répondre à vos questions vous faites
tout sur votre app qui fait que par
exemple si vous avez un sinistré que
vous allez en sait rien boire au
honduras
et bien vous pouvez venir déclarer le
sinistre directement là bas ils vous
êtes couvert de toute façon dans le
monde entier donc ça c'est très
rassurant ses hôtes peu rassurant vous
n'avez pas de carence dès que vous
activez l'assurance vous est couverte
vous n'avez pas de majoration en cas de
sinistre vous avez le droit à un vol par
an et deux sinistres de casse par an si
vous vous le faites voler plus d'une
fois par an vous n'avez pas de chance
voilà vous n'êtes pas couvert ça il faut
le savoir vous pouvez choisir votre
contrat avec ou sans franchise ça
modulera un peu le cri il ya surtout un
point moi qui m'intéresse c'est que vous
avez pas moins de 180 centres agréés
dans toute la france parle de france
métropolitaine ici les dom tom alors
allons tout de suite vous n'en avez pas
ce qui permettra de faire réparer
facilement dans 80% des cas la
réparation sera sous 24 heures et si
elle doit durer plus de 24 heures on
vous
ce sera un smartphone de valeur
équivalente on va donc réparer votre
smartphone s'il n'est pas réparable
on va le remplacer avec le même modèle
et de même valeur et s'il ya aucun
modèle de disponibles au marché et bien
on vous rembourse l'inscription est très
simple vous avez juste à aller sur votre
application vous rentrez vos données vos
coordonnées vous choisissez le modèle a
assuré vous prenez une photo de votre
produit passerait bien évidemment c'est
un assureur un assureur il va être sûr
que le produit fonctionnel au moment où
vous allez l'assuré ont maintenant les
assureurs vous savez et ensuite vous
activez l'assurance quand vous en avez
besoin
si vous prenez un contrat à la demande
si vous activez le contrat dès que vous
avez souscrit l'assurance vous avez 14
jours pour le résilier si ça ne vous
convient pas et si vous n'avez pas
encore activé bien vous avez 30 jours
pour l'annuler et sur tous les points
qui m'intéresse le plus c'est que vous
ne payez cas l'utilisation
moi par exemple yahoo n'allège pas venir
baptiste être deux trois ans j'étais en
vacances j'avais mon smartphone jeter
sur des rochers je voulais faire des
jolies photos de la mer en face de moi
fait une fausse manip le smartphone
tombe il a éclaté et là vous dit mince
je suis a pas embêtés justement
l'assurance la l'aurait pris en charge
même si c'est moi qui fait une fausse
manip ça c'est extrêmement rassurant
pareil j'ai un ami qui savaient voler
son pétrole l'année dernière s'est fait
voler deux fois son pétrole or ce
n'était pas le même
parce que forcément il y en a racheté un
autre il se l'est fait revoler et je
vous passe pas eu nombre d'amis qui se
sont fait voler leur smartphone
également ici un truc il faut savoir il
ya une petite nuance sur le vol s'est
comparé ici de vol avec violence c'est
quelqu'un qui vous a violenté pour vous
voler votre smartphone
si vous avez du vol avec malice c'est à
dire un pickpocket qui vous le pic sans
vous en rendiez compte
eh bien vous n'êtes pas couvert par
l'assurance le seul moment où sont
couverts par l'assurance et jaunissent
et sur du vol avec violence il faut
qu'ils aient un dépôt de plainte auprès
du commissariat et avec le dépôt de
plainte à ce moment là votre assurance
vous prendra en charge votre cas vous
avez des enfants vous prêtez la tablette
aux enfants pour qu'ils regardent leurs
dessins animés et arrive à un moment et
bien mauvais geste la tablette tombe
l'écran est abîmée voilà pas de chance
il y a vous êtes assurés vous êtes chez
vous vous êtes entendre garder votre
téléphone vous allez pour tirer la
chasse d'eau dans les toilettes
le téléphone tombe dedans s'il n'a pas
certifié résistant à l'eau et bien il se
peut qu'il soit endommagée et une fois
de plus dans ce cas là votre assurance
d'avenir agir pour vous réparez où vous
le changez donc il ya plein de cas de la
vie courante pas toujours en déplacement
il ya plein de moments importants où on
risque d'abîmer un objet du quotidien
objets qui nous est cher et qui a une
certaine valeur donc c'est pour ça que
cette assurance un sens est intéressant
il ya aussi un autre point à connaître
c'est que les produits de plus de 24
mois ne sont pas assurés simplement pour
éviter la fraude
autre point qui est bien et qui
différencie les autres contrats que j'ai
connus avant lorsque vous voulez résilié
et bien vous n'avez pas envoyer un
courrier recommandé vous faites tout
100% online avant la date anniversaire
bien évidemment bon ça c'est dans le
contrat moi je trouve ça intéressant
parce qu'on vient consommer l'assurance
différemment est forte on la consomme en
fonction de ses besoins et de ses usages
on n'est pas bloqué avec un contrat vous
avez ces trois mois minimum certes mais
vous vous dites par exemple à l'aise en
déplacement professionnel là je pars à
un endroit là je me sens plus à risque
vous pouvez donc l'activé la désactiver
quand vous souhaitez c'est une façon
différente de consommer l'assurance je
voulais vous en parler dites moi c'est
ça peux d'ailleurs vous vous intéressez
est ce que vous vous êtes déjà assurée
pour vos biens électroniques quel qu'il
soit et est ce que vous pourriez bourg
est assurée est-ce que vous avez des
expériences négatives sans assurance ou
alors expérience négative avec une
assurance
est-ce que vous avez déjà cassé un de
vos biens sans être assuré et vous vous
et dimas
si j'avais été assurées à ce moment là
eh bien ça s'est passé différemment et
est ce que ça vous est déjà arrivé
justement de casser un bien et d'être
assuré
et à ce moment là que votre assurance
prend tout en charge il doit tout ça en
bas en commentaire cela détourne à fossa
intéressant parce que c'est une façon
qui est différente de venir consommer
l'assurance tout le monde va pas se
sentir intéressés à prendre une
assurance pour me rassurer ses biens
électroniques
mais ceux qui le sont et ce qu'ils le
souhaitent eh bien je trouve ça vraiment
bien qu'ils aient cette alternative
qu'elle soit différente vous puissiez
activer/désactiver à la carte gérer vos
sinistre 100% online ou vous soyez dans
le monde entier vous avez qu à trouver
une connexion wifi vous déclarer votre
sinistre et il est pris en charge
directement
voilà moi trouve ça très cool j'ai mis
le lien en bas d'un description si vous
voulez vous assurer dans les meilleures
conditions
bah tout ce que vous en pensez en bas en
commente axa l'on se trouve extrêmement
rapidement pour utilisable par les tec
parce que croyez moi croyez moi il ya
plein de battre s'ils arrivent à la
parole aux frimas
you will genia soit essaye de faire